- Who on the cast do you think
would make the best neighbor
and the worst neighbor?
Ooh!
- I'm gonna let him go first
'cause I'm curious his answer.
- I go to sleep early, so I'm
not gonna make a lot of noise.
But then the kids during the day,
maybe I'm not a great neighbor.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- I love the process.
- Yeah, I- oh, for sure
Beth, because Beth bakes.
- [Kelly] Beth would be the best?
- I said Max actually, as mine.
Like, I think Max would
be the best neighbor, too,
because he's very considerate, very kind.
He would like come over and
babysit if I needed him to.
Like I feel like he's a good dad-
- Reluctantly, but I would do it.
- No, you would love it. You love babies.
You would love it.
- Yeah, I know. But it would
be, I would make a whole thing,
like, you would have to be like,
"Oh my God, you're so great."
And I'd go like, "Oh."
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- Secretly, I'd be
really excited about it.
But Beth bakes in a very real way
and doesn't bring a lot of it
to set, which is not great.
- Oh.
- [Beth] I know, but-
- I want to be your neighbor.
(Beth, Kelly, and audience laugh)
- [Kelly] Okay. Well everyone experiences
some awkward neighborhood moments,
but how would we react in those moments?
We are going to find out
with a neighborhood round
of "I'm Awesome at Being Awkward."
♪I'm awesome at being awkward ♪
(audience cheers)
- Is that the "Seinfeld"-is
that the "Seinfeld" theme?
(Kelly and Beth laugh)
- Here's what we do, when I say go,
our super random super computer will flip
through millions of awkward situations,
choose one, and we'll all have to say
what we'd do in that situation.
Let's go.
- By all, do you mean everyone here?
- [Kelly] Everyone here.
- (laughs) Everyone gets a turn.
- [Kelly] All, everyone,
it's gonna be a minute.
(ding)
Okay, you see your neighbor
walk past his garbage can
and dump something
suspiciously heavy into yours.
What do you do?
Now, I feel like this
is a different answer
depending on where you live.
Because here, trash is a-
you fill up those trash cans,
you stay outta my trash can
because we fill them up,
and you only get so
many, and they come by,
and, like, in Texas, it's not a big deal.
But here, it's a big deal.
I'm intense about this answer, wow.
- I don't like confrontation,
so I'd probably be like,
ooh, dead body, I don't know,
I'll, like- it's okay as long as
I don't have to get in a
fight with you, I'm good.
- I love that I didn't go dead body,
I just meant like there's not enough room.
(Beth, Kelly, and audience laugh)
- It says, "Suspiciously
heavy," so I was like, "Oh."
- I went dead body immediately.
(Beth and audience laugh)
I'm calling the cops.
- Yeah? Already, for that?
- I'm just, but I'm just coming-
I'm fresh off of, of
Evan Peters and "Dahmer,"
it's too much for me.
I'm calling- I'm going right to the cops.
I go, "I'm sorry, Netflix scared me".
(Kelly and audience laugh)
There's someone putting
something in my garbage can.
(group laughs)
- I think I'd just be like,
there's no room in the inn.
But here's another. Okay.
(ding)
- [Max] Oh my God, this is so long.
- [Kelly] This is so long.
- [Max] I can't read all that.
- [Kelly] Your neighbors accidentally
leave their blinds open and you, oh,
and you accidentally make eye contact
with one of them as they're
having intimate "nekkid" time.
- [Beth] "Nekkid?"
(crowd laughs)
- "Nekkid" time. They
make fun of me because
I say "nekkid."
So what do you do when
you see them the next day?
I mean, you know what I'd do?
"Well done."
(audience laughs)
- So I, I've, uh, I've done this.
- You've done this?
- I've, by accident-
- Wait, have you been the
person or you've seen it?
- I've been the naked one by accident.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- And I- it- there was a rabbi,
it was when I was in college,
and it was a chabad house
that I lived next to.
- You dated a rabbi?
(audience laughs)
- And, and it- I just was
rushing to get to class one day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I got out of the
shower and I forgot something
in the living room and I went out
and I locked eyes, full on rabbi, like,
praying, like, in his bedroom.
And, and it was like, "Ah! Ah!"
It was like a sitcom moment for sure, yes.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- But I've never done it again.
I'm very conscious of my body.
- I'm not, if you look at
my house and see something,
that's your problem.
- Oh, I like that answer.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's my house.
- Yeah, rabbi. It was my house.
- My house. You close your blinds, yeah.
- Yeah. Can't pray the naked away.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- [Beth] Or something, I don't know.
What about you? Wait, have you ever,
have you ever caught someone, or?
What would you do? What would you do?
- No, I, I, I had a similar, well, I'm-
- [Beth] Oh boy.
- I'm a little stuck on what's-
what intimate, "nekkid" time is.
- Intimate "nekkid" time
is, you know what intimate-
bow chicka bow bow.
- So I- so I see- so I-
I just don't believe
that's ever gonna happen.
That I'm gonna look in the-
I'm gonna look in the window.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna make eye contact
with two people that are having sex.
- Are you serious?
That's never happened to y'all like in a-?
- Have you ever lived in a city?
What are you talking about?
- Yeah, or, like, or in a
hotel in, like, New York?
I think this has happened,
like, a few times to me
where I've been like, "Oh my
God. Well done, well done."
I was like, like, yeah,
that's totally happened.
I'm rooting for you.
- [Max] Well I'm- I'm- I'm excited
to experience it for the first time.
(Beth and Kelly laugh)
- I don't know what I'd do.
- Or maybe you'll be the one doing.
- Oh, congratulations.
- [Beth] I'm gonna call Tess after this.
- [Kelly] Congratulations.
(Beth and Kelly laugh)